so we are ready to begin
thank you for joining us today welcome
back to the free webinar
on omix logic data science in today's
session
our team will be sharing information
examples and an
overview of the omics logic training
resources
designed for anyone to learn data
science for biomedical data
as seen in application to projects
sourced from current
topics in biomedical research
over the course of the past several
years
our team has been collaborating with a
number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly evaluated and are
known to lead
to excellent outcomes importantly the
programs are designed to support
students with minimal bioinformatics
background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
the goal of the omics logic programs are
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and
peer example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
the program is designed to offer an
introduction to statistical analysis
and machine learning and a broad
overview of technologies
and project examples to learn about
and develop practical data science
skills
using user-friendly cloud technologies
as well as
r and python coding
omits logic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed
in collaboration between pine biotic and
the tauber bioinformatics
research center what we will discuss
today is a result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders dr
alfred tober and dr leonid brodsky
alfred tauber comes from a medical
background
and has extensive expertise in
oncology immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
data science training and applications
in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
tauber bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics he
has numerous publications in mathematics
and bioinformatics and over the course
of his career
has developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes
experts in bioinformatics computer
science and training
some of our team will be presenting
today
so let me introduce you to the mentors
and the speakers of today's session
we have our ceo and co-founder ilya
brodsky
in his current role he has extensive
experience
working together with industry and
academic partners
that are applying multi-omics
integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications julia panoff
is a bioinformatician
and has developed many of the resources
we use
for the omics logic programs dr harpreet
kaur is our omits logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician who will guide
the sessions
and assist participants with projects
and analysis during the program her area
of specialization is cancer genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project
mentor and an expert in big data and
computational biology
to start today's session i would like to
invite ilya to
speak now thank you elia and over to you
thank you very much peeps
sorry elia must have some technical
issue
so he'll be joining in a minute as i see
uh maybe by that time you can uh tell
them about the attendance certificate
people are actually sharing
sorry about that disconnected
uh let me get back to my presentation
okay
so uh welcome everyone to this webinar
and i'm really excited to be able to
share with you
a couple of things about this upcoming
program now i have to mention the reason
why we are doing these webinars the
reason we're doing these webinars is
because we
know that there is an increasing
interest
in bioinformatics and in data science
there's a variety of people from
different backgrounds
and so we're hoping that we can explore
how we can adapt the elements that we
have designed and developed for the
omixlogic programs
to assist you at your level now we're
going to introduce to you
some of the topics that we will cover in
the program we will give you
an example from cancer research
presented by dr harpreet kaur
and we'll also talk about some of the
general challenges
as well as opportunities for those of
you that are interested in data science
how to develop skills that are needed
and how to make sure that you understand
the logic of the analysis which is
the main objective of these omics logic
programs
this is not a workshop where you will
get
hands-on experience and develop
skills the reason for that is because we
have only limited time
and really we are exploring how to best
allow most of you to join
one of the upcoming programs or benefit
from some of the resources that we have
available online
so for those of you that have joined to
receive a certificate
unfortunately this particular webinar
will not come with a certificate it's a
free informational webinar about an
upcoming program
for those of you that feel that the
content of this
webinar is not informative
that is okay this is intended to
introduce you
to the upcoming program that we will
cover
but we do hope to learn more about you
and to really take away the feedback
from the type of people that join these
programs and join these webinars
to make sure that we can be more
effective at what we do
so again thank you for joining and i
wanted to start by asking you
a couple of questions both about your
current level education
and if you mention your education
whether you're in high school
you have an undergraduate degree
graduate degree or postgraduate degree
if you would like please share with us
also
what institution do you currently work
for or study at
be it a school a university or a company
we would love to know and we will save
it in our records
so that we know where people are
primarily coming from
now for those of you that are coming
from an international
institution we obviously are encouraging
you
to continue and attend these webinars
but we also have specific programs that
are designed for different time zones
and for different localities so that's
one of the reasons why we are interested
to understand more where you're coming
from
so to answer the questions that we will
have throughout the webinar
we will ask you to just put in a number
so number one would be high school
number two undergraduate degree number
three graduate degree and number four
postgraduate degree
so please put your answer in the chat
excellent thank you very much for
sharing this information now
the reason why we're asking is because
we know from previous programs
that about 75 percent of all of our
participants
have either a master's or a phd
in some area of life sciences
and that is why a lot of the materials
that we have
are focused on that audience
that either has a graduate degree
or a postgraduate position or
they intend to pursue that career path
so you're genuinely
interested in research problems you
understand how
data is becoming a major part of
answering those research questions
and one of those reasons drives you
to pursue more experience with
bioinformatics
and gain more data science skills so
that's why
i come to my second question the second
question is
what do you expect from this program so
uh thank you for everyone that answered
uh unfortunately if you did not answer
uh that is fine we'll actually
guide you to a free course where you can
fill out a
full uh survey about your background
but my second question is about what do
you expect
to gain from joining this upcoming
program so this webinar as i mentioned
is
informational but we're really
wondering what might be the outcome that
you are most interested in so here are
the options number one
is to learn about omix data analysis
number two to get familiarized with data
science and data science skills
number three an overview of statistical
and machine learning methods
or number four apply data signs to a
research project
okay or five all of the above
all right excellent i i think this is
very exciting for me to learn
also and this confirms what we are
striving to do with these omics logic
programs
we are designing these programs to help
you both learn
and apply these skills to a research
problem so today
we will talk about some of the skills
talk about some of the resources that we
have to help you develop those skills
and then we will also talk about an
example project
that dr harpreet kaur worked in her
research which has to do with genomics
data in cancer and discuss how similar
types of projects
you will be able to develop during this
upcoming program
so first let's talk about bioinformatics
and data science and i know that there
has been a discussion in the online
community
about both similarities and differences
between the two
so as you know bioinformatics itself has
these three components statistics and
maths computer sciences
and biology and so when we speak about
data science a natural
question is why are we now speaking
about data science as something new and
not continuing to just speak about
bioinformatics
and so let me briefly speak about what
is typically expected from
a bioinformatician so a bioinformatician
is not expected to be an
expert in everything but they should
have some practical experience and that
practical experience is shown
in a project but here are some general
skills that one might expect
from a bioinformatician working in a
research lab
they should have domain specific data
processing
and quality control general data
transformation
and filtering applied statistics and
machine learning
applied means that you don't necessarily
understand the theoretical components
but you know
how to apply them efficiently general
data visualization and reporting tools
as well as very domain specific data
visualization
specific data integration so you know
how to work in an environment
where you might have to use apis
databases
and specific types of files that have
been compressed
and being able to write code with
version control for data analysis tasks
the code should be reusable efficient
and documented
and many people in the lab are required
to write python or r packages
for reuse so we will typically
develop a script or develop some kind of
a function
that other people need to be able to use
and finally an important component of
this
is being able to communicate data driven
insights or stories
in publications posters and
presentations
including multiple interactions with
people that have
minimal data science or computer science
background
that should still understand the
insights that we're bringing to them
now how is this different from data
science itself data science
includes statistics and maths computer
science
and also some kind of a specialization
so really when we
talk about data science it is much more
agnostic of the domain that it is
applied to
so according to uh such course
platforms like udacity the essential
skills of a data scientists
are programming machine learning
statistics data wrangling
data visualization and communication
data intuition and other
related skills so really the
components of data science and the
components of bioinformatics
are very much alike however when you
think about
the transferable skills the skills that
you're gaining
out of this course it is important to
think of it
as a building block for your career path
or as a building block in your
research so one of the benefits in
learning
data science apart from bioinformatics
is that you really gain
a wider broader perspective
on how to apply data processing
data wrangling visualization and
analysis skills
to a variety of data sets that come your
way when we speak about bioinformatics
oftentimes bioinformaticians are going
to have a very specific
niche focus that prevents them
from being able to deal with new
problems effectively and so
this program is going to be able to
provide you with
a broader overview of some general
skills
that will go beyond your typical
bioinformatics training
now some of these skills are going to be
very important also in application
to biomedical research and biological
research which does fall under the
domain of bioinformatics so you will see
a lot of overlap now what are some of
the data challenges and opportunities
that are
happening in biomedical research as we
speak
over the past 20 years there has been a
phenomenal growth
in adoption of high throughput
technologies like next generation
sequencing
which is both more and more affordable
and
widely adopted in biotechnology
where people rely on insights and
regular
generation of data to drive experiments
and validation
as well as in the pharmaceutical
industry
and clinical practice these technologies
produce an exponential growth of data
that one has to deal with to
get insights about a biological
phenomenon
or about a clinical application
now in parallel to this being driven by
companies
a tremendous amount of data is publicly
accessible
which means that many of us as we
learn about bioinformatics as we learn
about these data types
have access to data sets generated in
professional labs
that all of us can start analyzing
however we're also facing a challenge
and the challenge is that this big data
trend has produced
a big data problem that precludes many
biologists and clinicians for
gleaning knowledge from these data
regarding the nature of malignant
processes
and the relationships between clinical
phenotypes and their molecular drivers
so this program will allow you to
get some exposure to the nature of these
big data sets
and see how data science skills can help
you address
some of these challenges to make
biological interpretation now what do we
mean
by biological interpretation or
biological
insights that we glean from these raw
data sets so these data sets like omix
technologies for example
next generation sequencing is a
sequencing of dna or
rna material found inside the cell we
can also talk about
phenomics which is the visual
and phenotypic characterization of
biological samples and here we can see
phenomics for example could be an image
of
cell lines so when we look at the image
and we can characterize the shape
and the different properties
of these cells we can generate what's
called phenol phenotypic
data that phenotypic data is
generated by looking at the outside
of the biological sample but omics data
from the molecular perspective generates
data about what's happening on the
inside for example when we talk about
dna sequencing dna sequencing
generates information about
the differences in the dna of a
particular
sample from a reference genome
and so here you can see an example of a
table of somatic mutations
that produces a characterization of
different types of mutations relevant to
cancer
now over the past several years maybe 20
or so
there has been a growing interest in how
the genomic information gets
translated into functional proteins
and that goes through the process of
epigenetic regulation so this is
information that is not stored in the
dna
but still affects gene expression
finally it has been known that you can
easily study protein composition
by looking at mrna and microrna
expression so we can
capture rna from the cell and we can
study
alternative splicing as well as level of
expression of different genes
so together all of these technologies
provide
a massive amount of information about
what happens both
on the outside and on the inside
of the cell as a result giving us
insight
into how we can understand molecular
drivers
of conditions that might have clinical
and basic mechanistic insights
into the biology now all of these kinds
of data sets
actually help us understand
this data but they first need to be
processed
so when we process this data we are
generating
different types of structured data from
raw sequencing reads and these this is a
major component of bioinformatics is to
understand the technologies
that generate this kind of data and
build pipelines
that will process this data and turn
them into structured tables
once those data sets are structured
downstream analysis
helps identify specific
types of patterns that are associated
with the different types of data
that were generated for example we can
talk about
uh different types of comparison of
conditions and finding
variable patterns we can talk about how
those patterns could be mapped
on the structural properties of
different proteins and their
interaction we can talk about
multivariate analysis of big data that
allows us to summarize
thousands of data points into a visual
interpretation that might have
association with phenotypic data and the
process goes on so
the mastery of these types of processing
and downstream analysis methods pertains
to bioinformatics
specialization in these different types
of omics datasets
now in the clinical or biomedical
applications
these types of methods help us explore
the relationship between clinical
or phenotypic for clinical types of
conditions
data and omics data and the major
objective of such interaction and
finding such association
is to be able to improve the precision
of
diagnostic bio assays or
biomarkers and the application of
therapeutics
so design discovery repurposing
and assignment of specific treatment
combinations
to patients that have complex conditions
so a good example for that
might be cancer where a lot of times we
don't have
a clear target or there's resistance to
different types of treatments
or we need to detect cancer earlier so
we'll talk about an example
in just a few minutes when dr harpreet
starts talking so in the context of
these different challenges
we can look at how to process analyze
visualize and interpret these different
data side
data sets to be able to generate a
portfolio so when you want to tell
somebody
i know data science or i know
bioinformatics the way to explain to
them that you know bioinformatics or you
can apply data science is to demonstrate
using a project data set so for this
upcoming program
we have prepared a number of curated
data sets sourced
from cutting-edge research that is
peer-reviewed and comes from
high-quality publications and
high-quality labs
so that all of you can gain access to
some of these examples
and try to apply the same methods to
diagnostics and cancer biology
which we'll talk about today but also
single cell and tissue composition
as well as the microbiome and infection
so you'll be able to actually
study these different data sets and see
how these data sets can be
informative in the context of clinical
application now when we speak about the
data science part of this
process we need to understand how the
whole data science process
works so we need to talk about the
experimental design
and what factors or perhaps biases
it can introduce into the data set
we talk about the process of cleaning
filtering
and preparing the data set for analysis
how to do exploratory data analysis when
we use
visualization and data mining to find
patterns that might be informative and
interesting and oftentimes
that generates a hypothesis
the hypothesis in a clear
data science perspective is different
from what we call
a hypothesis in the biological sense
in the biological sense a hypothesis
is typically about some condition
that has an observable pattern
that could be validated through
statistical analysis
when we talk about a data science
hypothesis
we are talking about designing a model
out of the many potential models that
are out there
you have to understand what a model can
produce
but also what factors need to be
accounted for
in each particular model and so the
design of the model
that includes multiple statistical tests
and that can include machine learning
models that need validation
and that need a certain criteria for
passing the validation
all of that falls into the domain of
data science being able to
translate the data analysis
into a model and then provide
significant information about the
performance of the model
and the different outputs of that model
to communicate
with biologists and clinicians and so a
big part of what we'll do in this
program
is try to highlight some of these
aspects
and allow you to try them on your own so
that you understand
how this process works overall
now obviously i mentioned machine
learning and data mining and so
it would be useful to explain exactly
what i mean
by mentioning these terms there has been
an increasing interest in data mining
machine learning classification deep
learning
and artificial intelligence so i think
from the perspective
of a data scientist that works with
biomedical research data
i think the utility of some of these
models
is tremendous in particular it's
important to highlight
that previously when we relied on simple
statistical models
oftentimes we were limited by the
ability to deal with
big data sets that contain a lot of
variation
that does not conform to the statistical
assumptions
about data which was generated before
we see this emergence of high throughput
data
so there's a lot of heterogeneity
there's a lot of
features for each sample and there are a
lot of challenges
in finding complex associations
between feature to feature and feature
to
the object description or the phenotype
so what we'll do in this program is
we'll take a look at some of these
commonly used basic machine learning
models like decision trees
or like discriminate analysis and see
how computational methods that help with
feature selection that help with the
robustness
of models that we describe and help us
improve
accuracy and the predictive power of
these different models
has led to an emergence of this field of
data science for machine learning and so
we'll talk about
the different models and the different
use cases for when these models
and the selection of the appropriate
model actually
plays an important role in biomedical
discovery
now it's not only important to know the
statistical principles
and to apply the models in some sense
it has become easy there are visual
interfaces
and simple packages that you can call a
very complex
model with a single line of code
but what's important is as you
understand the variety of methods
and different data types and can match
the two to
answer a question or to generate a
hypothesis
you also need to make that model
explainable
you need to communicate the results to
your collaborators that come from the
world of
biology biomedical sciences clinical
sciences
or even the world of business that
includes business of research where
there's funding and there's
a different translational value to
different projects
to explain what you have found in the
data
and why that is significant and so we'll
spend con
considerable time speaking about
methods of visualization that are
intuitive
and informative for
non-bioinformaticians or non-engineers
so to give you an example of how such
projects are taking place today
in the world of cancer biology and
in the world of clinical application of
bioinformatics
i wanted to introduce you to dr harpreet
kaor
she is a trainer with the omixlogic
programs
and she will also share from her
experience during the program when it
starts in october
but today i would like her to introduce
some of her research background
and explain how some of these
methodologies have played a role
in the research that she has done in her
phd
please heartbreak you can take it over
uh heartbreak are you there
she says she is not able to unmute her
thank you
for such a nice session
so my name is harpreet kaur and i have a
phd
in bioinformatics my research is on
biomarker discovery for diagnosis and
prognosis of the liver cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and a lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is sixth major cancer in terms of the
incidences wide well
worldwide and fourth in terms of
mortality
liver cancer is often times misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an any
effective treatment
another factor that contributes to poor
outcomes
for liver cancer patients is the
frequent reoccurrence of the tumor
so with these concern in mind i have
framed number of research objectives
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using bioinformatics
for the first project of this research
we
use last scale transcriptomics data to
identify
a diagnostic biomarker panel for the
hepatocellular carcinoma which is a
major
primary malignancy of the liver cancer
so in this study we employed 30 data
sets
that containing nearly 4 000 sample to
lucid transcriptomics biomarker panel
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
liver cancer
implementing various statistical and
bioinformatics techniques
for the next part of this research
project we use
transcriptomics and methylation data to
identify biomarker panel
for the stage classification of
hepatocellular carcinoma
here we employ a tcga data set
of 350 samples and elucidate 51 features
that include 30 rna transcripts
and 21 methylation cpg sites using a
number of data mining approaches
the name based model classified early
in the lead stage samples of
hepatocellular carcinoma
with with an accuracy accuracy nearly 79
percent
for the third part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize the diagnostic biomarker
panel
for the clangio carcinoma which is
another major
liver cancer malignancy so in
in this study we employed nine data set
that containing 350 calendrio carcinoma
133 adjacent non-tumorous and 90
hepatocellular carcinoma sample to
scrutinize clencho carcinomas specific
transcriptomic signatures
implementing a number of machine
learning techniques
like extra tree svm rvf
rent that is random forest logistic
regression
then lda etc
so in conclusion we identify a universal
platform independent three gene
based biomarker that can predict hcc
patients with high precision and also
purchase significant prognostic
potential
then we identified a three gene based
clenzio carcinoma specific
specific transcriptomic signature
that uh that is capable to discriminate
cca samples from scc and the normal
with uh with an accuracy nearly 90
percent
so at last we identified a biomarker
panel of 51 features
that include 30 rna transcripts and 21
methylation cpg site
to predict the hepatocellular carcinoma
at an early stage
so during this program i am looking
forward to being your mentor
during the this comics logic data
science program
and help all of you learn about data
analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to the large data set
used in the biomedical research
in this program i will be speaking about
the role of big data please
in biomedical research that can generate
a hypothesis
that is then analyzed and used for the
accuracy improvement
and how this process is actually
affecting clinical cure
now i would like to hand over this
session to dr mohit majumdar
who is the present mentor at pine
biotech so over to you dr mohin
thank you doctorate just let me share my
screen
hello everyone my name is mohit mazumdar
and i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
my phd was focused on developing a
noble method to identify and predict the
binding affinity of calcium binding
sites
so as a result i had to master data
mining and become proficient at
predictive
modeling in my current role i am
collaborating and working with academia
and industry to provide support for
bioinformatics education and research
i have 12 years of working experience
and collaborating with
pharma healthcare industry to solve high
priority scientific
questions related to biomedical data
analysis and bioinformatics capacity
building
so as elia mentioned there has been a
remarkable shift
over the last decade in the cost of
generating molecular measurements
so it's just not genomes or dna
sequencing but
also transcriptomes proteomes and
metabolomes
so most impacted by this change is the
area of genomic medicine
where it is now possible to move from
generating reference or population level
data to producing data for
for individuals so we are getting data
from individuals
and concurrently there have been also
advances
in the development of new algorithms and
tools
to integrate and interpret this data
so bioinformatics is playing a key role
in all healthcare industry
and especially in pharma industry so the
pharma industry
is now considering data science and
bioinformatics
to be a very important part of their
portfolio if you see this latest
survey you will find out that ai and big
data
have the biggest impact
however to understand this application
and to be able to find information from
this
big data it is important to learn from
the analysis strategy
that we have been discussing and you saw
the analysis strategy that dr harpie
showed and get experience working on
real data sets
that elia talked about so together with
our research collaborators from top
universities
we have prepared projects for you that
takes you through
a project based approach where we take
data sets from high
impact publications and use them for
practical exercises
so it is you know kind of difficult to
imagine
what the biomedical industry will look
like in a few years time
but it is certain that this surge in
biological data flow will continue
and this increase in data will be
because of many large innovative
research projects
such as the international human cell
atlas initiative 10
that aims to create comprehensive
reference map of
all human cells and also get data from
devices like
apps wearables and implantable
technology
so in this upcoming data science program
we will learn about
analysis strategies and
methods and getting hands-on experience
on real data sets and i'm really excited
to be a part of this data science
program
co-mentoring and working on working with
students and researchers and i'll be
happy to help you
learn the concepts and application of
data science in biology
so with this uh let me pass it on to
miss deep chabitwa to take this forward
thank you everyone
thank you so much uh dr mohit
so i wanted to take you through some of
the
uh okay let me just share my screen
first
through the different program okay and
as you're sharing your screen
uh maybe i can just answer a couple of
questions that are coming up here in the
chat
yeah so the questions that you have
could be divided up into two parts
the first part is technical how
can you actually get access to the
program
what type of training will be included
what
is the registration process and all of
these questions will be addressed right
now
by uh beeps as she walks us through the
different resources
and the process of registration now the
other questions
are regarding bioinformatics and data
science
so things like how to mine raw data
or maybe where to find the specific data
sets that you can practice with
maybe the differences between different
types of methods
so all of these questions come up
typically
and require some time to address
for example it's not obvious how machine
learning is different from statistical
methods
or maybe different types of machine
learning models
differ in their prediction quality so to
understand the differences and the
technical components of each one of
these
analyses and the different types of data
will have to go through a series of
lectures so
when beeps shows the process of
registration she will also
highlight the schedule of the upcoming
programs
and introduce you to a variety of
resources that you'll have access to
in a schedule interactive sessions like
today
as well as asynchronously so you'll have
access to those materials
and you can use them during your own
time
on your own schedule and the two
work together to produce the omics logic
program
so i hope that that clarifies it a
little bit and
please go ahead pipsa thank you so much
elia again so
uh first of all let's talk about the
registration process
so here i am putting a link in the chat
box
this is the link to register for this
program which is starting
on the 12th of october and it is a
completely one month program
which will discuss about data science
and machine learning for omics data
so as you scroll down through the page
and you can do that
right with me as i'm speaking you will
see
the different details of this program
and the next thing are the different
session topics
so as you see that in the first session
which is
again on 12th we will be talking about
the introduction to data types and
properties
and on october 14th we'll be talking
about big data challenges and
opportunities and so on
and so forth so we will be starting
at a beginner level and slowly advancing
so there is a lot of questions that we
get who is this program for
and just to clarify to everyone and now
that we know that all of you are coming
from different
levels this program is suitable
for undergraduate students who are just
starting out
and are interested in learning more
about data science
as well as for faculty and researchers
who are working in this domain
so as you scroll down more you will find
different resources and you will find
some testimonials as well from our
previous participants
an overview of the different courses
and here you will meet our team so
how do you register here you can click
on get started and you will be given
three options to register so
the basic registration or the beginner
registration will give you
access to all of the resources that i
will be showing you
in a few minutes but
the intermediate uh
membership will give you access to not
only
the basic resources but also one-on-one
mentor support
so if you have any problem during this
entire one month period you can actually
get on a one-on-one
zoom call with our mentors and talk to
them
to solve your issues so that is what the
intermediate
membership is about and the advanced
membership is for anybody who is doing a
data science project so you want to not
only learn but take it
one step further so you can opt for this
membership because this will allow you
to go beyond this one month period which
is
till november fourth and do your
data science program and your research
project for
another 30 more days so if you have
any questions regarding this you can
always reach out to me at marketing
at pine.bio for more details
and now once you have registered here
and
you chose any of these memberships that
you would want to go forward with
you will get access to a profile like
this so here i have one profile
from a previous participant and as you
can see that
gracia is from sri lanka
that i can understand because he wrote
about it right here
and what he is doing what he is working
on
you can find right here he has also
added his social media link
so this profile serves as a really nice
way
to make a portfolio of yourself for not
only
the program participants but also for
anybody else who is a member of our
growing community
they are able to interact and
collaborate and i'll be
giving you some examples in a few more
minutes and as you see
grace has a certificate so as we
mentioned
this particular webinar does not offer
you a certificate but you can definitely
earn a certificate when you join one of
these programs like this so you see
grace as a certificate of excellence
so we got we give out a certificate of
excellence
or a certificate of completion depending
on how you're performing during a
program
and also you can see an independent
project that
he developed along with his
collaborators
so these are some of the opportunities
now let's talk about the resources that
you will have
access to as part of this data science
program
so the first resource you will have
access to is this
forum page or the organization page
so this page will serve as a classroom
or as one place from where you can
access all of the different courses
materials even the discussions
we have a dedicated forum which i'm
going to be showing you
and also here is mention all of the
different sessions
for the upcoming days so you will be
able to see the timetable as well here
and then you have a forum so
what is the utility of the forum the
forum
offers you the chance to see any news
that is posted
any updates on the sessions to interact
with each other and to ask
questions so say for example we have a
session on the 12th of october and after
the session you had
quite a lot of questions so where do you
ask these questions you post them right
here
on the forum by creating a topic that
you can do
from right here and once you create a
topic it will be posted
and we will be able to address that in
the upcoming sessions or
also reply back to you right here so
that is what the forum is about
then you have access to a lot of
different courses
so these are only an overview of the few
courses that you have access to but you
have accessories part of this program to
a lot more
uh so you see we have these few courses
which are dedicated machine learning for
biomedical data
and also the pca biomedical data
visualization
in our as well as projects
so these are the asynchronous materials
that
elia has been mentioning besides the
live
sessions these courses and these
projects will help you learn
more about data science and
explore it on your own at your own time
and space
and moving on regarding the independent
projects as you see we have a lot of
independent projects that were developed
by our participants our research fellows
and you can find all of them at this
example
if you are interested in looking you can
go to each of these videos
and see what these different
participants have studied and
what they are proposing in their
independent research
so please go through this link if you're
interested we even have high school
students who have been successful
in utilizing the resources and
developing their own independent
projects which they later
presented at science fairs or won some
competitions in
so please take a look at that here is an
example
of a poster presentation
you can also take a look at this
and to keep in touch with everybody
beyond
our own community we have the facebook
and the linkedin group so i had shared
this
links before in the chat so i will be
sharing them again
in linkedin it is called omix logic
machine learning biomedical data mining
and high throughput data analysis
where we post about different
activities different research topics
as well as job news
so that is all from my end elia if you
would like to go ahead and share more
okay thank you very much peepsta and i
wanted to now
address an important topic that comes up
during these sessions
and the question of access
so the question of access is really
about those of you
that have minimal bioinformatics
experience already
that would like to benefit from learning
about bioinformatics and i want to
introduce you to two different
aspects of this problem so the first
problem is how not being an engineer
and not having the capability to code
from scratch
can you get started with analysis of
big data how can you mine publicly
available
big data how can you generate those
tables
that you can then visualize and
investigate for patterns
and even how can you develop a sense of
the logic
behind the analysis that we will be
discussing
in the first part of this program so
for those of you that are still with us
i would like you
to go to bio dot server.tbio.in
so this is uh the link in this link
uh you will have
a thank you beep set so on this link
you will see the areas of analysis so
please let me know
once you are on this site
okay you can just post yes or i'm here
in the chat and i will guide you
on what you can do next so we'll do a
little demo
and you'll be able to try it for
yourself
so please let me know once you're here
okay
we'll uh wait until at least a few
people
are on this page so we'll wait until
five people are on this link
uh if you could also post uh the first
demo credential
yeah i have posted both the credentials
so please try it with
uh yeah so if you could just use the
first one
beep suggest maybe remove the second one
for now
if you can okay so for those of you that
are on here
i see that maybe three people anyone
else
let's wait a little bit and maybe we'll
get a couple more people to get to this
link
okay so we've got four
so one more one more person once you're
there we'll get started
all right excellent so now you can see
all the way on the side you will see a
login
link so please press on
login and use the first credential
so info pine dash biotech dot com
and the password is one two three edu
test okay please let us know
once you have logged in this is
important if you would like to follow
along
okay thank you beeps of the username is
info at pine dash biotech.com
the password is one two three edu test
once you log in you will have access
to a demo that illustrates
how bioinformatics analysis pipelines
are
generated to produce structured data
from raw sequencing reads so let me give
you a demonstration
here on top you see the different areas
of analysis
analysis of next generation sequencing
data mass spectroscopy
structural biology as well as methods
for data integration
analysis and modeling what we'll do
today is we'll take a look at how to
take
raw sequencing read from next generation
sequencing rna-seq
experiments and transform them into
a table of gene expression that will use
them
to visualize using r
okay so first of all you click on this
down arrow and you can go to
the cell line project demo so you click
on the cell line project
and what you should see is this pipeline
builder
okay so for those of you that see what i
see
right here please put in number one
okay so number one when you start
your bioinformatics pipeline is you need
to
be in the pipeline builder
okay so let's build a pipeline first of
all we need to load the data
but as we load the data you have to go
through a series of steps to process
this data
each job produces a
transformed data set that the next job
will pick up
and pass it on so it's really like a
pipeline that water flows
in and you can generate different types
of output so here we have
the main steps listed which is
pre-processing
mapping and quantification so we'll
first
click on start here you will find a
number of
algorithms that are publicly available
and you can run them
on your computer as well but first
before running them you need to learn
about how they work what type of inputs
and outputs they produce
and what is the logic of using them to
answer specific biological questions
so let's go to top hat 2.
tophat 2 is actually a collection of
different algorithms
that includes multiple steps of data
transformation
and produces a number of different
outputs for example it will produce
a sam file a file that contains
alignment of reads to the reference
genome
so once you produce those reads and you
align them to the reference genome
you can identify junctions
between exons and that gives you a sense
of what kinds of transcripts are present
in your data set once you've identified
the transcripts that information can be
used
to map on the transcriptome or map on
transcripts
and generate a table of expression
that will look like this okay
so once we've generated the table of
expression we can complete our pipeline
and you will get an output so let me
know
how many of you have the output tables
so this should be a gene expression
table
okay now these expression tables
can be now studied using statistical
analysis
but for statistical analysis you need to
have a hypothesis you need to understand
what kinds of groups do we have
in our data what kinds of conditions how
do we compare them to each other
so now please come with me to a
different area
that will also go through in this
program and we'll see
how to use principal component analysis
to be able to
visualize what we have in this table of
expression
okay please go with me to
code.omicslogic.com
you actually have to register here as
well
you cannot use the demo but the
registration is free
so you can register for free and i'll
let you register
as we speak but just to give you a sense
of what you will have
access to throughout the program and
even if you don't join the program
just if you have access to these
tutorials
you will be able to work with these data
sets and analyze them
so here we start with an introduction
how do we take the table of expression
that we just generated
on the t my info platform which is a
gene count matrix okay and you can
download it right here
and here we apply a method of what's
called
dimensionality reduction so we reduce
the complexity
of this table that has thousands of
genes
and tens of samples
and once we do that we can analyze our
data
for different groups now before we jump
into how the method works
let's see the coding part of it so this
is a code in
r and you see that it's colors
indicate different types of syntax
the first part is loading different
libraries
so libraries are collections of
functions that have
inputs and outputs just similar to what
we just saw in the pipeline builder
but their objective is to simplify the
process
of writing code so you don't have to
write everything out you just
load somebody else's library and you can
call specific functions
from that library give it the correct
inputs and it will produce a result
so next we go into the input section
when we input a file
we intake everything that the file
contains
the names of samples the names of genes
and the numeric portion
which is actually what we will analyze
so once we have a record of what the
input file is
we can read that table and specify where
the header is
and importantly separate the labels
from the actual numeric data which is
the matrix
of gene expression now
the methods of analysis that do require
a lot of theoretical understanding
to practically apply them you need to
have minimal knowledge you actually have
to only know
the specific call function how to call
them
and how to pass parameters so here we
have
a call of a function called autoplot
that will sorry the library called
autoplot a function called pr
comp so we'll actually do the
the analysis for us and you can also
extend it
with different types of outputs so let's
see
how this actually works okay so
here you get to the code part of it and
if you have the right data set loaded
which is right here
okay you can just click on run and it
will produce an output right here in
the console now what we'll do in the
context of this program
is we'll try to apply this same method
to a variety of different data sets and
play around with the different
settings so that we can improve
upon these basic outputs so for example
here you can see
a 3d plot with the data set
that we analyzed you can also understand
the model
so you can understand how much variance
does each principal component contain so
to really go through
all of these elements we also have a
full course
and that course explains how this method
works
with a lot more technical detail about
every step of the way
so this is a little overview of some of
the activities
and resources that we will leverage to
make this program
effective interactive and enriching
because we will not only have
interactive sessions where we
talk uh and present the theoretical
background of different projects
but you also have independent time to go
through some of the materials
on your own
now for those of you that are new to
bioinformatics
i would like to recommend a different
program for you to get started
so before jumping into data science you
might be thinking
this seems very advanced for me i'm not
ready
to spend a lot of time and learn how to
code from scratch and how to
deal with these big data sets so i
recommend our introduction to
bioinformatics for biologists
a program that will simplify a lot of
the things that we'll talk about
and prepare you for next stages
for those of you that are more advanced
and you already feel like you are
ready to not only learn about these
methods
but actually apply them to a long-term
research project and your objective is
to publish
present a poster work on your master's
thesis
or incorporate bioinformatics in your
phd program
we encourage you to explore the research
fellowship
which is an opportunity to learn about
these methods
in the context of your own independent
research project
we meet once a week and discuss
progress on your project supporting you
with a system from our mentors
interactive community of interns that
are all working on
their projects so you have a way to
collaborate
get feedback from experts and answer any
kind of technical challenges
that you need to overcome
so again thank you for joining today's
webinar
i hope that these resources were
explained
clearly and thank you to bibsa that did
an excellent job
going through the technical details and
the logistics
you'll hear from us again by email we'll
follow up and see if you need any
assistance
with anything that we presented today i
do want to mention that
in all of the resources that we shared
there's
a free level so you don't have to pay
anything
to get started and what i would
recommend
is to get started with our course
on introduction to bioinformatics
so the introduction to bioinformatics is
a course
that provides you with a broad overview
of the way bioinformatics is used in
medical research basic research
agriculture biotechnology
and the pharmaceutical industry and it's
a great introduction to a lot of these
topics
as well as a survey that you can fill
out to let us know
more about you and help us design
a personalized plan for you to be able
to benefit
from the resources that we have so again
you can register here for free
create your profile become a part of our
community
and start learning for free and these
courses
have certificates that you get upon
completion even the free courses do
and you can explore very affordable ways
to continue and expand your knowledge
as you go through now also on this
platform the coding platform
there are a number of free courses here
as well
and there's a variety of different types
of courses here
including getting started with
bioinformatics on how to process
sequences how to deal with sequence
similarity
how to get started with data science and
r and in python
how to deal with genomic data
metagenomic data
and transcriptomic data and this list
will continue to grow as you become a
part of this
program thank you again
and uh thank you mohit uh for presenting
as well as harpreets for presenting
about your research project
we'll be looking forward to seeing all
of you in the program
when it starts on october 12th
thank you everyone thank you ilya thank
you